thank you so much Roni and hi everybody
it's a thrill to be here I assumed that
because we're talking about innovation
here all of you have some sort of
innovations in mind and I wish I had
time to sit down with each one of you
and hear what they are because that is
always so exciting and so interesting to
hear kind of people's ideas about
innovation and where they want to take
the world I am as Roni said an
entrepreneur depending on how you count
it
EFT is my third or my 19th startup I'm
also a former venture capitalist and I
used the information that I have learned
kind of hands-on in the trenches in
startups and VC to gather together
things that I teach to students and
executives at Stanford University my
teaching is based on about 30 years of
entrepreneurial and VC experience in
Silicon Valley bringing innovations to
market so this presentation is about
sharing those observations offering some
insights and actually I would like to
give you some really actionable tools
that you can use to figure out how to
bring your innovation your innovative
ideas to market so without further ado
let's go so as I said I've had the
pleasure of being in silicon valley
surrounded by innovation and IT for
about 30 years and when you think of
innovation you also think of technology
and the web and green tech and life
science technology but there are also a
lot of other kinds of innovation
innovation is a really really broad
topic you may not be contemplating the
next big internet-based startup but you
might be thinking about innovations and
distribution channels different ways to
get your products to market you might be
thinking about innovative new pricing
models or marketing programs or
packaging all those things are
innovations and all of them require
thinking through kind of what is this
market all about and how can we
efficiently understand our
petition and leapfrog them and do a
better job of knowing who our customers
are so let's talk about a few of these
innovations just to get started and get
those creative juices flowing this
consumer has many innovations that have
become status quo innovation has
completely changed the way that we
travel the way that we shop the way that
we listen to music and the way that we
capture memories and our lives are
forever changed by these kinds of
innovations but that's not the only kind
of innovation that there is this is one
of my husband's David favorite
innovations he's a amateur wine
collector and this packaging innovation
putting nitrogen in a bottle enabled him
to enjoy his favorite wines just one
glass at a time without ruining the
whole rest of the bottle so there's a
packaging innovation for you some of you
may have those kinds of ideas amazon is
an extremely innovative company
recognising that shipping costs were one
of the big deterrents to shopping and
e-commerce Amazon came up with Amazon
Prime which killed two birds with one
stone
it eliminated the shipping costs for
certain customers in it also engendered
loyalty within those custom within that
customer base the Amazon has had several
other innovations in distribution
regarding besides shipping including
distribution of video distribution of
music and a lot of other things we'll
come to later in this talk what's this
have any any of you guys recognize this
leafy green vegetable well this product
might have been found only in some real
high-end health stores health food
stores not too long ago and health some
creative genius marketing people got
hold of it and realized that kale is
extremely valuable for its antioxidant
and anti-inflammatory capabilities and
they managed to make this what used to
be maybe
a decorative plant in your garden into
something that is in every grocery store
and about as poss almost as popular as
lettuce these days that is what I would
call a huge marketing innovation but not
all innovations make it how many of you
have one of these in your kitchen yeah
me either
so we want to talk about how do we make
sure that your innovative ideas can
become status quo instead of go the
direction of the knife that toasts bread
while you slice or this even with a
really great brand some innovations
don't really make it
ladies and gentlemen have you tried the
legendary harley-davidson Cologne would
you try this apparently no one else did
either so I'm not sure that the image of
a rough tough biker hardcore biker
correlates to how you would really like
to smell so you got to really be
thinking about who your customers are
and some of you may be old enough to
remember this marketing innovation that
didn't quite hit the mark
well coke is an amazing marketing
company and certainly did their homework
with respect to their customers and
customer demand they missed the mark in
terms of understanding what their
competition would do in seeding the
press with some negative feedback and a
minority of customers that didn't care
for this new product and as a result
consumer sentiment took over and new
coke in 1985-86 didn't make it and Coke
was left to go back and reintroduce what
is now known fondly as coke classic so
how can you avoid having your
innovations in your products whether you
have a great brand like Coke and
harley-davidson or not how can you get
those to market well that's what we're
going to talk about but before we go
there let's look about at some of the
business-to-business innovations
so what works obviously
and here's another Amazon innovation
that has been hugely successful Amazon
Web Services as a pay-as-you-go IT
department basically that allows enables
the SAS industry in the SAS business
model so rather than going out and
buying hundreds or thousands of servers
from the major hardware providers you
can just pay as you go and this
innovation has completely revolutionized
business-to-business computing now I
worked at Sun in the late 80s Sun was an
extremely innovative company that
managed to leapfrog its competitors by
building better faster cheaper computers
back in the 80s and 90s so how did they
miss this major trend to kind of
pay-as-you-go computing those are the
some of the things that we want to avoid
another industry that's completely
changed be due to innovations is the
advertising industry we've gone from
print to online ads to contextual
advertising to social advertising so I
had the privilege of working in a
company in the early 2000s that
discovered a way to capture a consumers
interest while they were surfing in the
say on the cooking site and looking for
recipes for sloppy joes like this one
here and follow that at that consumer
when she went to the fashion sites
knowing that she was interested in
cooking and recipes being able to
deliver content to her that she would be
interested in even though she wasn't on
the page where she started so that
revolutionized the advertising industry
from advertising to pages to advertising
to people and what we've seen from there
is that has become increasingly annoying
as these advertisements follow us from
place to place and now brands are having
to be more engaging and more authentic
and communicate more with consumers in
the social area arenas like Facebook
LinkedIn Pinterest and others and
communicate with them authentically and
what's changed here is the advertisers
no longer really control their messaging
like they did back in the 50s and 60s
when Heinz created the hungry-man
ketchup ads now grants are having to
communicate with consumers the way that
those consumers want to be communicated
with it's a completely different thought
process it's a completely different way
of working with customers and
communicating and all because of these
major innovations that have been brought
to market and change the industry
another really interesting industry is
the CRM industry or customer
relationship management I was one of the
early early employees of clarify back in
the early 90s where we came up with a
system that allowed us to track customer
issues and solve their problems
efficiently and effectively and that
company was really focused on customer
satisfaction that was our whole goal
back then and we managed to build a
billion-dollar company solving those
problems for customers but were
superseded by others who followed us in
the industry like Siebel systems that
took what we did it clarify that to the
next level focusing on Salesforce
automation
they were then superseded by
salesforce.com which took all that
functionality and delivered it in a SAS
model how customers wanted to buy things
and now we're looking at what the next
phase of that might be maybe some of you
are working on innovations for customer
loyalty and bringing us kind of right
back where we started from focusing
again on customer satisfaction and how
to build those long-term relationships
with customers likewise the human
resources industry has evolved quite a
bit it's not rocket science to
understand that happy employees mean
happy customers mean a greater amount of
creativity and innovation in your
companies and having employees that are
engaged and excited about what coming to
work every day
creating new things they're going to
help propel that company your company
forward our or how to retain your
competitive advantage so the Human
Resources industry also has evolved from
tracking administrations and and benefit
to the next generation that allowed
companies like Yammer and success
factors both top-down and peer to peer
feedback and social engagement to the
company that I'm currently started and
running called Ypsi which drives
enforcement of company culture through
thoughtful gifts that can be used to
reward certain behaviors in the company
with employee rewards very simple
employee rewards and recognition
programs and we hope that someday that
will be become one of the business
innovation Givens just like PeopleSoft
Yammer and others that I've mentioned so
we talked about a lot of different
innovations there were a lot of things
we mentioned a few innovations that
didn't quite make it like the night that
toasts bread or harley-davidson cologne
innovation in the end is a big gamble
and I spent nine years in venture
capital looking at all kinds of
different innovations business to
business and consumer innovations and
there were three different aspects of a
business that we considered we looked at
the team we looked at the technology and
we looked at the market
so these different aspects of an
innovation are weighted differently
depending on what kind of business that
you are that you're building for
instance if you have a cure for cancer
and there's definitely a market for that
as long as you can meet the price points
a lot of companies make it because the
team is an incredible team with great
experience in bringing new innovations
to market and the ability to weather the
ups and downs of that
of that path but probably the area of
these of these three things that's the
least understood and the most often
underestimated is what it takes to
really understand a market as investors
we knew that you have a lot of control
over your technology you have a lot of
control over your team you do not have a
lot of control over your market so
understanding what's going on in the
market and figuring out when is the
right timing to build to bring this
innovation to market and who to target
who to work with that's the key to
improving your odds in the innovation
gamble so that will be my focus for the
rest of this webinar and as I promised I
will leave you with several tools that
will help you to to understand your
market and make the right decisions
about your innovation going forward so
it's really simple the bottom line as
this New Yorker kamek kamek says is as
an innovator you need to be a visionary
you need to be a dreamer but you also
need to be a pragmatist so as a
pragmatist before you put your product
on the market you need to find out will
it sell so that's pretty obvious right
so why do so many innovators and
entrepreneurs fail lots of different
reasons the technology could fail
turnout you can't build what you thought
you could build often well not so often
but sometimes the team implodes they
find out this is just too hard we can't
work together so let's stop doing this I
give up
but more often than than those the
reason for failure is a lack of
understanding of the market and there
are three common mistakes that
innovators make with respect to
understanding the market innovators the
first one is this innovators fall in
love with their idea
they get so excited about it I can't
tell you how many times I've seen seen
this they get so excited about it we
would have these these entrepreneurs
these innovators come to meet with us at
in DC and they would go on and on and on
about their products and they would
forget to talk about the customers they
would forget to talk about the team they
would forget to talk about the market
but nevertheless those innovators often
were funded and the mistake they would
then make is going off into their their
dark tubes and believing that because
they were funded or because someone
believed in them enough to give them to
finance their ideas that they should go
off and build that so off they went into
their dark cubes for six months or nine
months and built something and then
brought it to market and had several
issues when that happened they either
build the wrong stuff they deliver too
late or they completely miss the
opportunity to build relationships with
their early customers so the first the
first really common mistake here is that
innovators fall in love with their idea
and they talk too much instead of
listening the art of marketing is really
about listening and about understanding
your customers and where they're coming
from
so rather than as this picture
illustrates standing up and giving a
PowerPoint presentation about what your
products are I want to see this I want
to see a conversation like these people
are having so it's about understanding
where the customers are coming from and
really listening and sometimes getting
that hard news back that what you
thought was fabulous doesn't quite hit
the market doesn't matter to your to
your potential customers so much better
to engage in conversation and listen
okay
moving on to the second really common
mistake that we see is that an
entrepreneur thinks that bringing new
products to market is about the product
and the reality is it's not it's about
the customers creating markets is
all about customer need and
understanding where they're coming from
so here's a trick question for you what
do customers care about and had I known
we had this little polling thing roni on
have built that in so I'm guessing that
you're thinking they care about return
on investment they care about
ease-of-use they care about quality they
care about all kinds of things about
your product and the reality is think
again what customers care about is
themselves customers care about their
problem and do you have a solution that
solves their problem does this french
fry holder that fits in an automobile
cup holder solve a problem that
customers care about I don't think so
this customer cares about where does my
drink Oh what do I do is my hamburger
when I have to stop the car really fast
and the french fries they're still in
the bag so what you have to do is get
out and talk to the customers and figure
out what is their real problem and this
is where what I call the three C's come
in you need to demonstrate that you
comprehend the customers real problem so
that's the first C then you need to show
that you are competent to addressing
that problem or bringing that
opportunity to fruition and the third
thing you need to show is that you care
that you care enough about solving this
customers problem or bringing this
opportunity this customer that they can
trust you to to do that for them so the
three C's are critical and if you put
aside your belief that it's all about
the product and and realize that it's
all about the customer there's a lot of
ways that you can connect with that
customer that adds to have absolutely
nothing to do with your products
so what they care about is your
expertise what they care about is that
you really understand where they're
coming from and that you and can be
trusted to solve their problem so the
three C's and that is the foundation for
for building new markets and finding
those first customers the third mistake
that entrepreneurs make is that they get
out there they go okay I get it that
it's not about me I get it that my
product doesn't matter it's about the
customer and I need to be open-minded to
changing my ideas about what my product
is and and not being too in love with it
but most the problems they go out they
start talking to customers but then they
start then they ask the wrong questions
so a lot of three is not enough most
customers are not so good at vision
customers are are in the present they're
solving the problems they have they're
realizing the opportunities that they
have right now and so asking them about
something a year from now two years from
now even six months from now you're not
going to get a really good quality
answer because customers are bad at
vision many of them and secondly even if
they're good at it they don't want to
disappoint you so they're going to tell
you what they think you want to hear so
how do you address that well first of
all don't ask them to gaze into this
magic 8-ball and predict the future
focus on the present focus on what's
going on in customers lives today and
really understanding that so you can
then do the interpretation yourself and
map what that means on to your vision
and where you see your innovations going
so what I'm saying here is to improve
your odds of bringing your innovations
successfully to market and before you
build out your innovations get out and
talk to potential customers I'm showing
a lot of customers here because it takes
getting a lot of feedback to really
understand where the market
opportunities are what you need to do at
this stage before you even build out
your innovation is is understand where
the market is and where your where your
sweet spot in the market is so you need
talk to a lot of different customers and
identify the very specific market
segments and targets that are going to
be the biggest opportunity for you and
and get you some successful reference
accounts so don't fall in love with your
products too much realize that it's
about the customer not the product and
realize that you need to understand
where they are today in order to have
them adopt your vision of the future so
when you get out and talk to these
customers what is it that you need to
know well a lot of innovators go
straight to the product of course you
need to know feedback on what is it that
the product needs to be or the service
so but it's not just in the big picture
what does this product need to be what
you need to figure out is what is the
Minimum Viable Product that I need to
develop in order to bring it to market
to meet the needs of the sweetspot
target my target market so what I mean
by that because that was a lot of
buzzwords here is figure out who is the
best first few customers for you in what
market segment and then figure out what
do those customers really need what's
the absolute minimum I can build to get
a product that meets their needs in
their hands as quickly as possible we
refer to that as the MVP or the Minimum
Viable Product because the sooner you
can get product to market and in the
hands of your customers and building
reference accounts the sooner it is that
you start to create a market because
it's not a product that creates a market
it's not your advertising campaigns or
your logos or things like that
it's customers that make a market so you
need reference customers to build a
business and bring you other customers
become references who build a bigger
business that's what it's all about so
but and that's where a lot of innovators
and entrepreneurs stop they figure out
okay what's my product and and when who
am i targeting but they miss out on the
first four or five different items on
this list so the equally important in
getting out and talking to these
customers is figuring out what's going
on in the day in the life of a customer
so what are this customer's priorities
so again because a customer will tell
you what you like to hear you'll get out
there you'll start talking about what
you're doing you'll be asking questions
and they'll tell you that this idea is
the greatest idea since since the
toaster knife and what you're not
understanding is your idea is sixth or
seventh on a priority list for that
customer where they're only going to saw
answer the first three priorities so you
really need to be honest about where is
this in the customers priority you need
to also find out you know is this a
problem you have today and what is the
solution that you're using today so it
is that good enough you need to find out
competitors promises so absolutely best
source of competitive information is not
the competitors website in what's going
on today it's what are they telling
potential customers about where they're
going to be tomorrow don't make the
mistake that a lot of innovators make
about selling your future against what
you think against a competitor's present
those competitors are selling their
futures as well so you need to
understand where not only where your
competitors are today but where they're
going and you can learn that in these
early customer interactions the next
question you need to understand is who
makes decisions is this a consumer
product where the consumer decides for
themselves or is this a business product
where that's going to take a team of
people and there's a decision maker
there are influencers and how exactly
are these decisions made and then the
next one obviously is who pays does this
person buy this product themselves or is
this the kind of thing where you need to
get millions and millions of eyeballs
and it's the advertiser
that's going to pay so then you better
understand what's going on with the
advertisers and that audience as well or
is this a b2b product where a group may
determine they need it but the CFO has
to improve the the budget so all those
factors are equally as important as what
is the initial product and who are our
first customers so what you need to know
is this how do we create the right
product for the right customers and
learn how to sell it before you run out
of money so if you're in a big
corporation you've been given a certain
budget to bring this innovation to
market all these things need to happen
in the context of that if you're a
startup and you're looking and you've
got some angel funding you need to make
all this research and all this
understanding before you run out of
money so that's the bottom line
now I promised that I would give you
some tips for for this first hand market
research so now we're going to get to
that part so the first tip is
face-to-face customer visits I I like to
go out meet with customers as many as
you can and figure out you know what is
a day in their life
what are what's going on it's going well
what's going on it's going not so well
it's not about you it's about the
customers and the day in their life you
may have a really great idea but if it's
not a priority for the customers it's
not going to get it's not going to make
the cut so just as an example for my
current company which services local
businesses we went out and talked with
60 different small businesses to
understand what was going on in their
world and we learned that if we're going
to provide a tool for different
merchants that it needed to basically
not cost anything and it needed to have
them not have to discount products in
order to sell through our service and it
needed to require zero IT so after our
60 meetings we said okay that's the
hurdle that we have to cross how are we
going to do that and we
completely reinvented what we thought
our product was going to be and ended up
with this gifting service
likewise along the way we analyzed the
data that was coming in about who was
using it and made a lot of course
corrections that it based on what the
customers were telling us along the way
so I would say if you're doing a b2b
business you need to talk to at least 30
potential customers and if it's a
consumer business and that's
face-to-face 30 different potential
customers in order to figure out where
your sweet spot is what your Minimum
Viable Product needs to be and how
you're going to sell this how decisions
get made if you're doing a consumer
product it's probably hundreds and there
are a lot of different ways to do some
do some of that face-to-face but there
are also some great tools like
usertesting.com they can give you honest
user feedback on some early prototypes
and designs and and really understanding
that you know that's a way to get you
face-to-face visits in a scalable way
okay
the next tip for firsthand market
research is ask questions all right and
I just gave you a whole bunch of
different questions that you need to ask
so who makes the decisions who approves
the decisions who are the influencers
where does the money come from so these
are all questions that a lot of
innovators especially those who are more
focused on product don't think of to ask
and you'll be amazed what customers will
answer if you simply ask what's your
budget for something like this how much
money my favorite question overall I
usually try to wrap up a meeting with
this after I've built some relationship
with the customer is please tell me all
the reasons you would not buy this
because that's what you really want to
know right that's what we'll tell you if
you know oh my gosh those are real
reasons I'll give you an example one of
the companies I worked in when I was in
DC was doing a scalable email server for
corporations back in
early 2000s and we went out and we met
with email administrators and we met
with CIOs all the way up and down the
chain of command in the IT organization
we met with end users who are suffering
from email problems and first of all and
we met with large corporations fortune
500s and we met with small consulting
firms that had ten employees so a huge
different range of customers to talk to
and honestly we found that some of the
best answers came from those email
administrators and they were probably
the easiest prospects to get meetings
with because no one ever asked an email
administrator what was going on in his
or her day and they were happy to tell
you what was working and all the things
that were not working and so we would
use that information to draw conclusions
that allowed us to get higher in
higher-level meetings until we got up to
the CIO level and the people who
controlled the budgets so think of a lot
of figure out all the questions all the
information you need to know then get
organized so all this this get organized
needs to happen before you go out and
start having these meetings and again a
lot of innovators and entrepreneurs will
get you know kind of jump to the
opportunity to go out and talk to
customers and they talked to 30
different customers and they end up with
pages and pages of notes in no format
that you can do anything with and it
still ends up being kind of a gut
feeling so I like to come up with a
one-page interview form look something
like this
not fancy at all but put the thought in
upfront to what is the information that
I really need to understand and I really
want to know from these customers make a
form and then use that in your meetings
however I would caution you do not just
go line by line down the form because
that's totally boring and you lose the
attention of your prospects again you
want to gauge them in a conversation so
you just kind of fill out the form as
you go and then as you're wrapping up
you can look at the form and go okay
which ones
questions did I not get any information
on you can go back circle back and and
fill them in the advantage of this is
it's a really efficient way to get the
data you want and it's a great way to
organize it because then after all these
meetings you've had in all these kind of
freeform discussions you can then
tabulate the results and draw the
conclusions that you need to draw to to
make your company decisions so that
little form looks pretty boring so think
about how can you make this fun for you
tea we worked with a team of Stanford
students on our really really early
market research and we're trying to
figure out what are we going to do and
these students were taking a class in
the design school which is extremely
innovative and creative and so rather
than going out and asking merchants who
were our target customers for feedback
on this idea they made little cards 3d
cards on poster board that and they had
words on them that could be problems or
features or priorities for for these
customers and they spread the cards out
all over the table and then let the
customers kind of pick up the cards in
the order of how important they were to
them so so much more interesting and
engaging than just walking down the list
or asking someone what their priorities
are so we love that and have used that
several times since I love this diagram
because this is another way to make it
fun someone's drawn a series of Venn
diagrams on the floor and put a bunch of
features on little post-it notes and had
their customers place those post-it
notes in the different Venn diagrams
representing different ideas that they
had so the more fun you can make it the
more engaged you'll get with your
customers the more great feedback so our
meetings are 15 minute meetings would
often turn into an hour lively
discussion sessions last but not least I
covered this somewhat cast a really wide
net you may have ideas of
where you think your target market is
and who you should be selling to but you
really don't know so put those ideas
aside and kind of like I was describing
with the email the email server company
you want to talk to people from
administrative level to executive level
you want to talk to people and companies
of 10 employees to hundreds of thousand
employees and that's where you're going
to get your best information based on
that you choose where is our sweet spot
where are we going to go with this new
innovation and what is our Minimum
Viable Product and then build a strong
relationship with those early customers
because in the end what you're trying to
get to is lots and lots of happy
customers he or she who has the most
paying customers wins very simply not
how much money can you raise not how
many employees do you have not that you
built a really cool product it's you
know are the dogs eating the dog food to
use an old thing so I have a few key
takeaways here and then I'm going to
turn it back over to Ryan first of all
as we said innovation is everywhere we
are constantly changing the status quo
there are constantly new Givens in the
b2b world innovation is not just IT it's
packaging it's marketing like with kale
its pricing programs its distribution
channels I gave you several examples of
those second innovators often make
mistakes don't fall to these mistakes
don't fall too much in love with your
idea make sure that you're open-minded
don't be too product focused and make
sure that you're asking questions that
customers can give you really good solid
answers on reflecting their real-life
experience third increase your odds of
success with careful customer research
you want to develop the right product
for the right customers at the right
time and you need to learn how to sell
it and finally here are some practical
tips for customer research your
face-to-face visits ask a lot of
questions get organized first make it
fun and cast a really wide net
and so with a little bit of investment
upfront to really understand your
customers it will pay off in spades to
bring the right product and the right
customers at the right time so good luck
and I will be back shortly to answer any
questions that you might have so I've
been reading some of your questions as
they've been coming in and let me try to
group some of them together one some of
you have been asking but how do you get
these customer meetings how do I get the
attention of the people we need to talk
to and first of all I would say early on
I'm not very picky about who we meet
with if I can get some good information
out of a customer I will go ahead and
spend time with them so for instance
you're in the b2b space what we learned
is it's much easier to get the time of
an administrator than it is of a CIO so
we tend to start with the grassroots and
meet with those people because those
people are often more accessible and
they have great information about where
the real pain points are and what I
learned from those meetings you're able
to kind of grow into going up the chain
level level by level up so you're
actually providing useful information
back to the companies in a consumer
oriented product or service it's much
more we work a lot starting out through
friends and family and say give me some
really honest opinions on this and kind
of go from there well who else do you
know that might be interested in this
and and get feedback that way I
mentioned also usertesting.com
which can give you some really good
customer face-to-face experience without
actually being face to face but you'll
get recordings and see the emotion in
their face as they're testing out or
using some of your products so long
story short I to get those initial
meetings you tap your friends your
family your colleagues your professors
pretty much anybody you know and go from
there
someone else asked about do these a
principle do these principles apply to
services as well as products and the
answer is definitely yes honestly I
think there's a really fine line between
services and products now almost
everything truly is a service if
customers are kind of paying as you go
in a SAS model while you're offering
offering is really a service not a
product if what you're offering is you
know something in the more traditional
services area like food services or spa
services or things like that still you
need to understand who your customers
are
so definitely applies someone else asked
how do we segment a market and the
answer is really I fill in those sheets
I gather lots of customer information I
look for common commonalities among them
so kind of from the bottom up
from the top down I'm looking at well
does this segment have the same needs
have the same behaviors have the same do
they read the same web sites the same
press the same articles are they how can
if I chose to go after this segment how
would I reach them with my marketing
materials what are the common
requirements that they have so typically
your your defining segments that based
on demographics psychographics
male/female geography a lot of different
criteria that that you would typically
use to identify a segment someone asked
to review the three C's so simply it is
comprehend do you comprehend the
customers problem do you are you
competent to solve that problem or
deliver on that opportunity and do you
care because in the end bringing a new
innovation to market is about building
trust with the customers who first adopt
that innovation so for to build that
trust they need to believe that you
comprehend that you're competent and
that you care
last but not least I want to leave you
with some references people have asked
where can we learn more some people said
some of the things that I've talked
about sound a lot like the writings from
Clayton Christensen
I love Clayton Christensen his work is
fantastic if you want to understand more
I would suggest some reading some of his
work I also am a huge fan of Geoffrey
Moore and crossing the chasm and there's
a lot of great marketing really
practical marketing of advice there
about how to bring new innovations to
market so I would highly recommend those
two authors in particular and in the in
in the area of bringing new innovations
to market we have someone asking about
do these principles still apply in a
mature market and how would they apply
so generally an innovation is something
that's new so I'm assuming that it's a
mature market but your innovative idea
is something that's different so I would
so yes it definitely applies you're
looking for what's different about what
this innovation is and how is that
different than what's been going on for
years and years in a mature market what
else one more question about someone
who's worried what would happen if they
talk too much about their new innovation
and it gets stolen so that is a great
question and it comes up all the time
and it's I'm glad you asked so the
answer is be careful that what I said is
figuring out who your customers are is
more about listening than talking
demonstrating the three C's that you
comprehend that you're competent that
you care also is more about listening
than talking so rarely does a customer
care about your secret formula or your
patents or how you built whatever
whatever it is that you're building they
care about themselves you don't have to
tell them all your secrets
they it's more about showing them that
you understand how you can solve their
problem so if you switch your mindset to
listening instead of talking you're not
really giving away all your big secrets
okay thank you very much with that I'd
like to thank Donna for joining us today
and for giving us a wonderful
presentation with lots of tips and food
for thought thank you again for joining
us have a good day